2 china rückkehrer infiziert die beiden
deutschen wurden positiv auf das corona
virus getestet und in die frankfurter
uniklinik gebracht
gegen ein tempolimit auf autobahnen die
csu startet eine internetkampagne
populistisch und realitätsfern sagen
kritiker und erster weltcupsieg für anna
bereiter die 20-jährige rennrodlerin
siegt in oberhof
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg sonntag der zweite
zweite 2020 willkommen zu einem kurzen
nachrichten überblick wo die tanne ist
auch dabei für den sport in etwa acht
minuten
hallo und land wieder beginnen wir mit
dem corona virus in china klettert die
offizielle zahl der bestätigten
erkrankungen immer schneller nach oben
auf mittlerweile fast 14.400 infizierte
und über 300 tote auf den philippinen
gibt es den ersten todesfall außerhalb
chinas
und hier bei uns hat sich herausgestellt
dass zwei der über 100 aus wo hahn
ausgeflogenen deutschen das virus in
sich tragen david sauer berichtet es ist
eingetreten worauf sie sich in der
frankfurter uniklinik seit tagen
vorbereitet haben
auf dieser isolierstation werden die
zwei infizierten untersucht und
behandelt am morgen erst hatten sie ihre
diagnose bekommen die zurück geflogen
wurden alle nach ankunft im frankfurter
flughafen untersucht ärztlich befragt
und von ihnen wurden brachen tupfer
proben genommen
das ist ein sehr zuverlässiger ist die
auswertung dauert allerdings einige
stunden um die heimkehrer nicht unnötig
zu belasten wurden sie in eine kaserne
im pfälzischen germersheim gebracht
zunächst auch die beiden noch
unentdeckten infizierten die anderen
bleiben für mindestens zwei wochen in
der quarantäne kaserne obwohl intensiv
geforscht und getestet wird sind noch
immer viele fragen rund um das kroner
virus offen
das ist eine dynamische lage wir kennen
den virus noch nicht abschließend wir
haben noch keine therapie schon gar
keine impfung und solange sich das nicht
ändert ist vorsicht das oberste gebot
auch weil viel unsicherheit in der
bevölkerung herrscht die lage ist auch
noch nicht im griff in china
offensichtlich und damit insgesamt nicht
und deswegen müssen wir eben jetzt auch
gemeinsam in dieser situation
dann damit umgehen immerhin alle bisher
in deutschland bekannten fälle seien
isoliert in dieser zeit sei wichtig dass
der staat funktioniere so sparen weiter
doch auch pläne für den fall einer
weiteren ausbreitung
bereit dominik löschmeister vor der
frankfurter uniklinik wie geht es den
beiden infizierten beiden patienten geht
es gut sagt die frankfurter uniklinik
sie sind auf der isolierstation
untergebracht bekommen da aktuell auch
noch nicht mal medikamente weil sie auch
keine symptome zeigen die frankfurter
uniklinik hat in diesem bereich auch
sehr viel expertise das liegt an der
nähe zum flughafen
aber auch wenn man hier durch andere
infektionskrankheiten wie zum beispiel
saß in der vergangenheit auch viel
erfahrung aufgebaut hat man wird diese
patienten diese zwei patienten 14 tage
hier in der klinik behalten in frankfurt
und sollte es in germersheim wo ja die
restlichen deutschen untergebracht sind
zu weiteren fällen kommen morgen soll
dann noch mal getestet werden
würden sie dann auch noch frankfurt
kommen die ärzte haben aber hier in
frankfurt auch noch mal deutlich gemacht
dass sie eigentlich vor dem corona virus
weniger angst haben als zum beispiel vor
einer grippe denn der korona virus
verlauf in europa bisher sehr mild
dankeschön nach vom foto mini bei einem
messerangriff in london hat ein mann
zwei menschen verletzt die polizei
vermutet einen terroristischen
hintergrund
beamte haben den tatverdächtigen
erschossen er soll einen gegenstand am
oberkörper getragen haben der wie ein
sprengstoffgürtel aussah tatort war ein
beliebtes wohnviertel im süden der
britischen hauptstadt
italien hat dem rettungschef open arms
erlaubt auf sizilien anzulegen
die 363 migranten gingen in porz alle
von bord die flüchtlinge waren mit
verschiedenen boten in libyen
aufgebrochen und tagelang auf see bis
sie dann gerettet wurden walter hatte
dem schiff untersagt anzulegen die csu
macht mobil gegen ein tempolimit auf
autobahnen sie hat im internet eine
kampagne gestartet und offenbar in
kürzester zeit einigen zuspruch bekommen
applaus dafür kommt auch von der afg
spott und kritik dagegen von spd und
grünen aus berlin
darum geht der streit volle pulle voraus
so schnell wie möglich so lange wie
möglich bloß nichts ändern
40.000 erklärt die csu hätten sich
bereits in ihrer kampagne beteiligt und
gibt verbal gleich nochmal kräftig gas
wir wollen mit dieser kampagne auch
deutlich machen wir wollen keine neuen
verbote in diesem land sondern glauben
an dieser stelle
es ist auch gut möglich mit
eigenverantwortung die sache gut zu
lösen
problematisch so die csu sein strecken
auf denen höchstgeschwindigkeiten gelten
bundes und landstraßen gefährlicher als
autobahnen und umwelt und klima bringen
ein tempolimit wenig den umfragen
hingegen sprechen sich die deutschen
mehrheitlich für ein tempolimit auf
autobahnen aus wegen des klimas aber
auch um schwere unfälle zu vermeiden
es geht darum dass freiheit nicht erst
mit dem bleifuß auf der autobahn zu
fahren sondern menschen zu schützen und
wer meint feuerwehr mit polizei wer mal
mit den unfall war tätern geredet hat
der weiß da wird schreckliches erlebt da
ist ganz viel wahlkampfgetöse dabei die
csu hat einigen grund abzulenken von den
missgeschicken ihres verkehrsministers
wir sind als spd grundsätzlich für tempo
aber wir haben es nicht auf die
tagesordnung gesetzt noch im oktober
hatte die koalition also auch die spd im
bundestag gegen ein generelles
tempolimit gestimmt inzwischen hat
selbst der adac über jahrzehnte
verfechter freien fahrens den kampf
gegen das tempolimit aufgegeben
in die sache kommt bewegung die
strompreise in deutschland steigen
weiter zahlreiche versorger darunter die
großen wie ehren und energie haben
erhöhungen von durchschnittlich 8,1
prozent angekündigt bei einem verbrauch
von 400 kilowattstunden sind das
mehrkosten von rund 100 euro im jahr
seit jahresbeginn haben damit drei
viertel aller grundversorger ihre
strompreise erhöht
im ruhrgebiet haben mehr als 100
umweltaktivisten das neue
steinkohlekraftwerk datteln 4 besetzt
und einen sofortigen kohle ausstieg
gefordert
die demonstranten waren offenbar durch
ein aufgebrochenes tor auf das gelände
gelangt datteln 4 soll im sommer ans
netz gehen entgegen der empfehlung der
kohle kommission am nachmittag beendete
die polizei die besetzung und jetzt bist
du dran
jede menge wintersport gab es heute
wieder stephan leyhe hat die ehre der
skispringer mit platz zwei in sapporo
gerettet nachdem karl geiger mit rang
fünf die führung im weltcup abgeben
musste ja und für weitere erfolge im
wintersport haben unter anderem die
deutschen rodler und rodlerinnen gesorgt
erster weltcupsieg für einer der reiter
beim rennrodel weltcup in oberhof mit
bestzeiten in beiden läufen kommt die
erst 20 jährige die ihre erste weltcup
saison fährt am besten mit den widrigen
bedingungen zurecht anschließend sorgt
sie noch mit dem sieg im teamwettbewerb
gemeinsam mit johannes ludwig und dem
doppelsitzer wendl/arlt für den
perfekten abschluss bei diesem letzten
weltcup vor der wm in sotschi francesco
friedrich lenkt den viererbob beim
weltcup in st moritz auf den für ihn
ungewöhnlichen fünften platz doch
friedrich holt damit eine von drei
möglichen kristallkugeln gewinnt vor
johannes lochner den weltcup in der
königsklasse doch wer wird heute dritter
schneller sind der kanadier justin krebs
und der lette oskars keeper mannes der
norweger jan man es lieber gewinnt
erwartungsgemäß souverän das triple der
nordischen kombinierer in seefeld der 22
jährige oberstdorfer vinzenz geiger
rechts belegt knapp platz drei hinter
dem zweiten norweger auf dem treppchen
jürgen crombach eric frenzel wird
fünfter und im ersten sonntagsspiel der
fußball bundesliga gewinnt erst fc köln
mit 4 0 gegen den sc freiburg köln
bleibt vierzehnter hat aber jetzt sechs
punkte abstand vom relegationsplatz
freiburg achter novak djokovic hat zum
achten mal die australian open gewonnen
im ersten grand slam turnier des jahres
setzt sich der serbe in fünf umkämpften
sätzen gegen dominic thiem aus
österreich durch
novak djokovic hat in melbourne die
gesten des siegers wieder einmal für
sich
genau vier stunden und fünf sätze sind
gegen den österreicher dominik team
nötig um in einem hochklassigen match
letztlich als verdienter sieger vom
platz zu gehen
für djokovic ist es bei den australian
open bereits der achte titel und für
dominic thiem die dritte finalteilnahme
bei einem grand-slam-turnier
der kurze sport am sonntag war das schön
noch zum wetter morgen wird es wieder
sehr nass im norden einzelne schauer in
der mitte und im süden kräftiger regen
und da warnt der deutsche wetterdienst
aktuell für überflutungen und
erdrutschen
die temperaturen sechs bis 15 grad
das war es von uns eben heute journal um
viertel vor zehn begrüßt sie claus
kleber wir verabschieden uns wünschen
ihnen noch einen unbeschwerten
sonntagabend